welcome to the presentation on torque so
if you watch the presentation on the
center of mass which you should have you
might have gotten a little bit of a a
glancing view of what torque is and now
we'll do a little more detail so in
general from the center of our mass
center of mass video we learned it if
this was a ruler and this is the ruler
center of mass and if I were to apply a
force at the center of mass I would just
shift the whole ruler in the oh I would
accelerate the whole ruler in the
direction of the force so if if I had
the force applying at the center of mass
there the whole ruler would accelerate
in that direction and we'd figure it out
by making the the force that we're
applying to and dividing by the mass of
the ruler and in that center of mass
video I imply well what happens if the
force is applied here away from the
center of mass well in this situation
the object assuming it's a free-floating
object it's on the space shuttle or
something it will rotate around the
center of mass and that's also true if
if we didn't if we didn't use the center
of mass but instead we fixed the point
so let's say we had let's say here's
another ruler although it has less a
height in the previous one instead of
worrying about its center of mass let's
say that it's just fixed at a point here
whoops let's say it's fixed here so it's
like I don't know this could be this
could be like the hand of a clock and
it's nailed down
to the back of the clock right there so
if we were to try to rotate it it would
always rotate around this point and the
same thing would happen if I were to
apply a force at this point maybe you
know I could break the nail on the back
of the clock or something but I won't
rotate this this needle or this ruler or
whatever you want to call it but if I
were to apply a force here I would
rotate the ruler around the pivot point
and this force that's applied a distance
away from the pivot point or we could
say from the axis of rotation or the
center of mass that's called torque and
torque the letter for torque or is this
Greek I think that's tau it's a curvy T
and torque is defined
as force times distance and what force
and what distance is it it's the force
that's perpendicular to the object I
guess you could say to the distance
vector right if this is the distance
vector let me do it in a different color
if this is the distance vector the force
is going to be the component of the
force it's perpendicular to this
distance vector and this is torque and
so what are its units will forces
Newtons and distance is meters so this
is Newton meters and you're saying hey
Sal Newton's times meters force times
distance that looks an awful lot like
work and it's very important to realize
that this isn't work and that's why we
won't call this joules because in work
what are we doing we are translating an
object if this is an object and I'm
applying a force I'm taking the force
over a distance that's in the same
direction as the force right here the
distance in the force are are parallel
to each other you could say the distance
vector and the force vector are in the
same direction in this situation of
course that's translational the whole
object is just moving it's not rotating
or anything in the situation of torque
let me switch colors the distance vector
this is the distance from the fulcrum or
the pivot point of the center of mass to
where I'm applying the force this
distance vector is perpendicular to the
force that's being applied so torque and
work are fundamentally two different
things even though their units are the
same and this is a little bit of
notational this distance is often called
the moment arm distance and I don't know
where that came from maybe one of y'all
can write me a message saying where it
did come from and often saw in some of
your physics class the locks off didn't
call torque as as a moment but we'll
we'll deal with the term torque and
that's more fun because eventually we
can understand concepts like torque
horsepower in cars so let's do a little
bit of math hopefully I give it given
you a little bit of intuition so let's
say I had this ruler and let's say that
this is its pivot point right here
right so it would rotate around that
point it's nailed to the wall or
something and let's say that I apply a
force let's say the moment arm distance
so let's say that this distance let me
do it in a different color let's say
that this distance right here is 10
meters and I were to apply a force of 5
Newtons perpendicular to the distance
vector or to the dimension of the moment
arm you could view it either way
so torque is pretty easy in this
situation torque is going to be equal to
the force 5 Newtons times the distance
10 so it'll be 50 Newton meters and
you're probably saying well Sal how do I
know if if this torque is going to be
positive or negative and this is where
there's just a general arbitrary
convention in physics and it's good to
know if you are rotating clockwise
torque is negative well let me go the
other way if you're rotating
counterclockwise like we are in this
example right we're getting
counterclockwise the opposite direction
of which a clock would move in torque is
positive and if you rotate clockwise the
other way torque is negative so
clockwise is negative and I'm going to
go into the whole physics the the whole
cross-product and the linear algebra of
torque right now because I think that's
a little bit beyond the scope but we'll
do that once we do more mathematically
intensive physics but so good enough up
you know there's a torque of 50 Newton
meters and that's all of the torque
that's acting on this object so it's
going to rotate in this direction and we
don't have the tools yet to figure out I
guess you know how quickly will it
rotate but we know it will rotate and
that's vaguely useful but what if I said
that the object is not rotating and that
I have another force acting acting here
and let's say that that force is let's
say that that force is let's say that
force is I don't know let me make up
something that's 5 meters to the left of
the pivot point
let me do a different color this is five
meters to the left of the pivot point
and if I were to tell you that the net
that this object does not rotate so if I
tell you that the object is not rotating
that means if the net torque the net
torque on this ruler it must be zero
because it's not well it's it's rate of
change of rotation is not changing I
should be a little exact if I'm applying
some force here and still not rotating
then we know that the net force the net
torque on this object is zero so what is
the force being applied here well what
is the net torque well it's this torque
which we already figured out and it's
going in the clockwise direction so it's
five we do it in a brighter color five
times ten and then the net torque the
total the sum of all the torques have to
be equal zero so what's this torque so
let's call this F this is the force so
plus well is this this force is acting
in what direction clockwise or counter
counter clockwise
what's acting in the clockwise direction
right this Force wants to make the ruler
rotate this way so this is actually
going to be a negative torque so let's
say put a negative number here times F
times its moment arm distance so times
five and all of this is has to equal
zero the net torque is zero because the
object the object is its rate of change
of rotation isn't changing or if it
started off not rotating it's still not
rotating so here we get fifty minus five
F is equal to zero 50 is equal to five F
F is equal to ten and if we follow the
knew the units all the way through we
would get that F is equal to ten Newtons
so that's interesting I applied double
the force at half the distance and
offset it half the force at twice the
distance and this should this should all
connect or start to connect with what we
talked about with mechanical advantage
right you could view it the other way if
let's say these are people applying
these forces this say this guy over here
he's applying ten Newtons he is much
stronger he's twice as strong as
this guy over here but because this guy
is twice as far away from the pivot
point he balances the other guy so you
can kind of view it as this guy having
some mechanical advantage or having a
mechanical advantage of two and and
watch the mechanical advantage videos if
that confuses you a little bit but this
is where torque is useful because if an
object's rate of rotation is not
changing you know that the net torque on
that object is zero and then you can
solve for you know the forces or the
distances I'm about to run out of time
so I will see you in the next video